ob eis oder schnee bei einer
stadtführung mit eugen wendler in
reutlingen geht es zur sache und zwar
künftig bis 1864 bis zur genau die
freiheit gab es zwölf fünfter und zwar
die bäcker dann die käufer hier die
kramer oder kaufleute die schuster dann
die metzger und auch die
mittelalterliche blütezeit liegt lange
zurück
heute ist reutlingen zwar eine reiche
stadt aber die sehenswürdigkeiten sind
nicht gerade üppig gesät
das alleinstellungsmerkmal der stadt
liegt versteckt in einer seitenstraße
genauer gesagt es ist die seitenstraße
wir gehen jetzt gerade mal durch
zunächst dachte die stadt man habe mit
der steuer hofstraße die ängste straße
deutschlands aber seit 2007 steht im
guinness buch der rekorde
es ist die ängste straße der welt
erfolgreich treibt reutlingen seither
touristen hier in die enge
doch jetzt schlagen die stadtführer
alarm denn der rekord von 31 zentimetern
ist sprichwörtlich ins rutschen geraten
die balken von hausnummer 9 sind morsch
und mit ihnen könnte der weltrekord
kippen
eigentlich wollte der bauträger das
ganze abreißen und neubau erstellen dass
da jetzt nun nicht weil die ängste kasse
so bekannt und berühmt geworden ist dass
man das unbedingt erhalten will aber
jetzt geht es zwischen der stadt und dem
bauträger das tauziehen hin und her und
keiner will so richtig den ersten zug
machen
weder der mieter des hauses noch der
eigentümer möchten vor die kamera man
arbeite bereits an einer lösung erklärt
die immobiliengesellschaft
der stadt reutlingen geht das aber nicht
schnell genug
die weiter höre ich gehe umso enger wird
die straße wird also enger als 31 cm
das wäre wirklich zu schade wenn das
ganze wie quer zu eng darf die steuer
ruf straße nämlich auch nicht sein
doch das marode haus kaufen und selber
sanieren hat bei der stadt keine
priorität
es gibt drei varianten es gibt die
variante natürlich der eigentümer
richtet das hat er jetzt bislang
abgelehnt und hat gesagt er hätte mehr
interesse ist zu verkaufen das wäre die
zweite variante ein interessent kaufte
das haus und macht da auch nicht schöne
nutzung ein
oder die dritte variante die stadt kauft
aber das ist immer so eine sache wo ich
sage eigentlich ist es schöner wenn ein
haus beliebt ist und nicht museum drin
ist für viele bürger unverständlich
wurde doch gerade eine neue stadthalle
eingeweiht
sollten wir schon was machen stellt man
stellt das war eine halle in für 42
millionen
also ich kenne viele leute die wegen
wegen der kleinsten straße hierher
kommen aber aber die stadthalle fühlt
sich keiner an das was da muss was
gemacht werden
auch historisch ist die straße für
reutlingen bedeutend denn sie erinnert
an den wiederaufbau der stadt nach dem
großen brand 1728 zusammen häuser sind
so hat das reutlingen auch etwas der
schwäbischen bescheidenheit zu verdanken
dass die stadt heute in einer reihe mit
weltberühmten straßen steht der kurve
chsten in san francisco der breitesten
in buenos aires der elegantesten in
paris der längsten in australien und der
teuersten in hongkong
und sollte es am ende wirklich zu
eng für den rekordwerten hat reutlingen
noch ein ass im ärmel versteckt in der
backstube dieser konditorei hier hütet
nicole speidel ein besonderes geheimnis
das rezept für die beste schwarzwälder
kirschtorte deutschlands denn die 27
jährige ist gleich zweifache deutsche
meisterin und mit einem nationalen
rekord hat es bei der engsten straße der
welt ja schließlich auch mal angefangen